er hat sich schon hingesetzt der
bundesgesundheitsminister hier in berlin
über den ganz deutschland den kopf
schüttelt impfen impfen impfen fordert
er und dann rationiert er aber den bayer
und teig impfstoff den lieblings
impfstoff der deutschen jetzt muss er
sich den harten fragen stellen von bild
von vielen anderen journalisten oben
rechts sehen sie schon live bild hier
aus der bundespressekonferenz also gehen
wir direkt rein jens spahn zu seinem
impfstoff versagen live
in der bundespressekonferenz zu gast bei
uns ist der bundesminister für
gesundheit sparen und an seiner seite
der präsident des paul ehrlich instituts
professor doktor klaus psycho tech und
der leiter der forschungsgruppe für
infektions immunologie und
impfstoffforschung an der charité herr
professor otto leif erik sande sie sind
zu uns gekommen natürlich mit blick auf
die aktuellen berichte und diskussionen
über das impfen mit den ligen stoffen
moderner und bayern tech
bundesgesundheitsminister beginnt dann
hätte speck und ein herr professor
sander bitte
er lieber herr de thier meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren vielen dank
für die möglichkeit angesichts der
aktuellen entwicklungen noch einmal die
hintergründe unsere aktuellen
entscheidungen darzustellen
was etwas unterzugehen droht in mancher
berichterstattung das ist mir vorneweg
sehr wichtig moderner ist ein guter
sicherer und sehr wirksamer impfstoff
manche impfenden ärzte sagen biontech
ist der mercedes unter den impfstoffen
und moderner ist der rolls royce und ich
denke das macht sehr deutlich dass wir
eben zwei sehr gute impfstoffe mehr
impfstoffe jetzt zur verfügung haben
sowohl für die erst wie die zweitimpfung
wie auch für die auffrischimpfung und
ich bin sehr dankbar dass herr professor
psycho deck und herr professor sander
das gleiche auch normal verdeutlichen
werden die deutschen werden momentan am
häufigsten den impfstoff von biontech
und das ist ja auch in ordnung so die
nachfrage nach dem impfstoff von barrick
ist allerdings in den letzten zwei
wochen sehr sehr stark gestiegen
allein in dieser woche heute vor allem
heute und morgen gehen sechs millionen
dosen des impfstoffes von bionic aus und
sein in die versorgung in deutschland
das ist mehr als es bisher überhaupt
insgesamt an auffrischimpfungen in
deutschland gegeben hat und das muss
jetzt auch erst einmal verimpft werden
in der letzten woche sind gut zwei
millionen impfungen in deutschland
erfolgt das heißt also wenn wir jetzt
sechs millionen heute ausliefern ist das
auch in relation zu den letzten tagen
und wochen eine große menge und insofern
baut sich wahrscheinlich an vielen
stellen im land über die ganze
versorgungsstufe arztpraxis apotheke
großhandel auch ein gewisser puffer auf
alles in einem ist das erst mal eine
gute nachricht die impfkampagne läuft
wieder und weiter hoch und viele haben
sich offenbar und auch das ist ja gut
anders als in den wochen zuvor jetzt
dazu entschieden eine booster eine
auffrischimpfung zu machen oder auch
anzubieten
leider ist der eindruck entstanden wir
würden nur deshalb stärker auf den
impfstoff von moderner setzen um einen
möglichen verfall dieser impfstoffe im
ersten quartal 22 zu vermeiden das ist
zwar ein wichtiger aspekt das will ich
ausdrücklich sagen natürlich auch ein
aspekt aber es ist nicht der
entscheidende
entscheidend ist dass sich unser
biontech lager so schnell leert dass wir
ab der nächsten woche vorübergehend
nicht mehr als zwei bis drei millionen
dosen des impfstoffs pro woche
zur verfügung stellen können für die
versorgung und das liefern wir dann auch
aus alles was wir haben und alles was
wir neu geliefert bekommen wird
natürlich ausgeliefert wir halten nichts
zurück ich gelegentlich lars am
wochenende insgesamt stehen so bis
jahresende und auch das ist richtig
insgesamt stehen so bis jahresende
24 millionen dosen des impfstoffs zur
verfügung wenn wir also damit planen
davon ausgehen dass wir 25 bis 30
millionen
auffrischimpfungen bis zum jahresende
machen wollen dann wird ein großer teil
dieser impfung wenn gewünscht
mit biontech stattfinden können und dazu
kommt noch moderner von moderner haben
wir 16 millionen booster dosen auf
fristlosen sofort in unseren lagern
verfügbar bis jahresende bis zu 26
millionen wir haben also von den beiden
m rna impfstoffen für erst zweit und
dritt impfung bis zu 50 millionen
impfdosen zur verfügung bis zum
jahresende das ist genug für alle
anstehenden impfungen
mir ist sehr bewusst dass diese
kurzfristige umstellung für viele
engagierte helferinnen und helfer vor
ort in den arztpraxen und den
impfzentren viel zusätzlichen aufwand
und auch stress bedeutet
geplante prozesse und abläufe müssen
umgestellt werden und sie müssen
überzeugungsarbeit leisten das weiß ich
und das bedaure ich auch
wichtig ist es ist genug impfstoff für
alle anstehenden impfungen da und beide
impfstoffe wirken wer die chance hat
sich
und andere mit einem der beiden
impfstoffe zu schützen der sollte ist
auch tun
danke herr minister natürlich denke ja
vielen herzlichen dank ich hab hier und
bei vieler gelegenheit ausgedrückt dass
die zugelassenen cofidis stoffe die wir
in deutschland verfügbaren hoch wirksam
und sicher sind an das anlass der
derzeitigen diskussion möchte ich noch
mal deutlich darauf hinweisen dass
gerade die beiden impfstoffe und zwei
aus teig wegs von moderner aber auch
community von beim tipp sich durch
besonders hohe wirksamkeit auszeichnen
und durch ein besonders niedriges
risikoprofil
wie sind äquivalent und das haben wir
anlässlich der derzeitigen diskussion
insbesondere auf unserer webpage jetzt
noch mal deutlich dargestellt mit so auf
die sicherheit in bezug auf die sehr
seltene nebenwirkungen die unter zehn
fällen pro 100.000 liegen sind beide
äquivalent die wirksamkeit und
effektivität in klinischen prüfung hat
sich als 90 prozent und höher
herausgestellt für beide impfstoffe die
dauer der des mundschutzes gegen kuwait
und insbesondere gegen schwere verläufe
auch in gegenwart der dominierenden
delta variante beträgt fünf bis sechs
monate und entsprechende priorisierung
bei der booster impfung sind inzwischen
getroffen worden und auch in bezug auf
die plattform und die immunologie die
hinter den impfstoffen steht sind diese
impfstoffe durchaus äquivalent und
deswegen für die hydrologie booster
impfung genauso wie die ruhelose booster
impfung sehr geeignet und sie ergeben
dass zeigen publizierte studien hohe
antikörpertiter erhöhung nach der
booster impfung ich möchte auch noch mal
bei diesem anlass darauf hinweisen dass
beide impfstoffe zugelassen sind für die
auffrischimpfung und zwar fällt es sich
so wie sie sicher wissen dass hier bei
der biontech luster impfung dieselbe
dosis verwendet werden soll wie bei der
grundimmunisierung die halbe dosis bei
spex moderne angesagt die entsprechende
präsentation ist da so dass das kein
problem ist im rahmen der gmk beschlüsse
aber auch in bezug auf die stiko
empfehlungen möchte ich noch mal
deutlich machen dass die
auffrischimpfung mit spikes für personen
ab 30 jahren empfohlen werden kann das
entspricht auch der stiko empfehlung und
für alle schwangeren ab dem zweiten
trimenon für person von 18 bis 29 jahren
sondern nach stiko empfehlung kumulativ
verwendet werden hier wird einfach
berücksichtigt dass das register studien
zur sicherheit der impfstoffe aus
nordischen ländern geht die
kreativität wie wir sagen das heißt die
vorübergehenden inflation im rahmen der
erste ball bis fünf tage zwischen spikes
und community sind durchaus äquivalent
mit einer tendenz zu etwas deutlicheren
in fraktionen bei der zweiten und sicher
auch bei der dritten impfung wir haben
auch in unserem letzten
sicherheitsbericht zum ende september
nochmals klargestellt
wir müssen einmal ganz kurz erklären
warum professor biotech der chef des
paul-ehrlich-instituts ist so
ausführlich über den impfstoff von
moderner redet wo wir alle was über bei
und hören wollen der grund ist ein ganz
einfacher es gibt enorme verunsicherung
in den praxen und bei den patienten über
die moderne impfstoff weil die stiko die
ständige impfkommission empfohlen hat
die nicht an unter 30 jährigen nicht an
schwangere zu impfen das ist ein echt
und dass jeder hat das kennen wir von
von astrazeneca da fing das auch sondern
das ist die befürchtung der deutschen
dass mit dem impfstoff irgendwas nicht
in ordnung sein könnte das ist nicht der
fall und das räumt gerade der professor
hieraus
impfstoffe auch die zelluläre
immunantwort
ansprechen gehe ich davon aus dass auch
die erhöht werden kann
zusammenfassend kann man sagen bei den
stoffen sind äquivalent können home open
catwalk für die booster impfung
verwendet werden da gibt es keine
zweifel in bezug auf die datenlage in
bezug auf die zu lassen und zur auf die
studien die nach der zu lassen
inzwischen untersucht und ergebnisse
gebracht habe vielen dank dank herzlich
weg und der professor sander
vielen dank vorweg zu sagen bevor wir
nochmal über die details der booster
impfung sprechen vielleicht noch mal
vorweg einfach finde ich es wichtig noch
mal zu sagen dass die die steil
ansteigenden inzidenz und die sich
zuspitzende lage muss man ja sagen in
den krankenhäusern intensivstationen in
erster linie
einer nebel zu niedrige impfquote
geschuldet sind wir haben ja in
deutschland das große glück und das
haben wir gerade gehört freien zugang zu
den besten sichersten und modernsten
impfstoffen gegen 9.10 zu haben und wir
müssen dieses geschenk unbedingt
annehmen es besteht aus meiner sicht
überhaupt keinen zweifel dass wir heute
in einer komplett anderen situation
wären wenn sich alle erwachsenen in
deutschland ergeben hätten es ist
vollkommen klar wir bekommen normalität
nur durch immunität und das funktioniert
nachhaltig eben nur über eine
flächendeckende impfung und deswegen
müssen wir alles unternehmen um die
impflücken zu schließen wir wissen aber
auch das haben wir im verlauf des jahres
festgestellt
dass der impfschutz nach zwei impfungen
mit der zeit etwas nachlässt und
insbesondere auch der schutz vor
infektionen und weitergabe des virus mit
der zeit abnimmt gerade wegen der hoch
ansteckenden delta variante und sich
deswegen zunehmend auch geimpfte wieder
am infektionsgeschehen beteiligen können
bei älteren vor erkrankten personen
sieht man in israelischen daten zu
nehmen leider auch in deutschland kann
zudem der schutz vor schwere erkrankung
leicht nachlassen wobei zu betonen gilt
das ist immer noch deutlich ist deutlich
besser und deutlich über dem niveau von
ungeimpften personen insgesamt sprechen
aber alle daten klar dafür dass es
letzten endes auf 1 3 dosis schema
hinauf hinauslaufen wird so und ich habe
beim letzten mal an dieser stelle ja
schon ziemlich viel über die vorzüge der
booster impfung gesprochen und herzig
und herr spahn haben das ja auch schon
getan aber vielleicht noch mal um das zu
verdeutlichen die daten aus israel legen
nahe dass mit einer booster impfung der
schutz oder das dass das risiko einer
erkrankung noch mal um das 10 bis 20
fache gegenüber zweite hälfte reduziert
werden kann und jetzt gibt es auch daten
aus placebokontrollierten studien die
ebenfalls die effektivität einer booster
impfung mit 95 prozent gegenüber der
regulären zweifach-impfung angeben und
das sind alles effekte die sehr
beeindruckend sind und den
herausragenden nutzen der dritten
impfung noch einmal darlegen im logisch
ist es auch nicht überraschend
wir kennen das ja von anderen
impfstoffen und mit der 2 nach der
zweiten impfung bekommt das immunsystem
sozusagen ein wenig zeit um nach zu
schärfen und mit der dritten impfung
werden dann spezifisch diese
ausgereiften gedächtniszellen noch mal
aktiviert und der der impfschutz kann
dadurch nochmal deutlich verbessert
werden und diese effekte müssen wir
jetzt konsequent nutzen daher die breite
buser kampagne wie sie jetzt ja auch
angelaufen ist und glücklicherweise ja
auch genug impfstoff zur verfügung steht
müssen wir jetzt beschleunigen generell
wird empfohlen und herzig als auch
gerade schon gesagt dass die dritte
impfung mit einem m rna impfstoff
durchgeführt wird und das ist unabhängig
davon welchen impfstoff sie für die
grundimmunisierung verwendet haben sie
können 1 mm stoff verwenden die
kombination unterschiedlicher impfstoffe
ja sogar unterschiedlicher impfstoff
typen ist problemlos möglich das konnten
wir im frühjahr unter anderem bier und
viele andere in studien zeigen dass die
sogenannte kreuz impfung sogar
immunologische vorteile bieten kann und
mittlerweile ist die studienlage
dazu auch sehr sehr solide
für die booster impfung legen wir uns
aktuell zwar die größten datensätze für
den biontech impfstoff vor jedoch gibt
es auch sehr sehr gute daten für den
impfstoff von moderner beide impfstoffe
und der tecdax gesagt sind von der
bauart im prinzip identisch
die bisherigen studien könnten sogar
nahe legen dass moderner geimpfte einen
leichten vorteil lagen könnten gegenüber
biontech kämpften meiner meinung nach
ist das quasi ein akademischer
unterschied den man sich angucken das
marginale unterschiede auf hohem niveau
die beiden impfstoffe wirken beide sehr
sehr gut und
fest steht einfach dass wir mit diesen
zwei impfstoffen zwei hoch effektive und
biotech auch gerade einmal ausgeführt
hat extrem sichere impfstoffe zur
verfügung haben
somit ist aus meiner sicht mit hinblick
auf die wirksamkeit die wahl des mr
impfstoffs für die booster impfung
eigentlich egal ja da sind sicherlich
auch die führenden in monologen
hierzulande einig wir haben uns auch
noch mal in den letzten tagen gesprochen
dessen beides hervorragende impfstoffe
die für die booster impfung gleich gut
funktionieren und
wie er tagaus sagte wissen sie dass für
personen unter 30 jahren aktuell
prioritär der biontech impfstoff
eingesetzt werden soll und daher ist es
aus meiner sicht auch vollkommen logisch
dass zum beispiel impfungen bei älteren
je nach verfügbarkeit auch primär mit
moderner durchgeführt werden können
wichtig ist an dieser stelle nochmal zu
sagen dass moderner für die booster
impfung in der halben dosierung also 50
mikrogramm eingesetzt wird weil da und
das ist auch so der letzten stiko
empfehlung zu entnehmen
kurzgefasst beide impfstoffe
funktionieren sowohl in der
grundimmunisierung als auch in der
booster
impfung ganz hervorragend man kann im
grunde genommen sagen sie können
beruhigt das nehmen was gerade da ist
beide impfstoffe werden sie sehr sehr
gut schützen und beide sind sehr gut
verträglich und die stiko sieht das
übrigens in ihrer letzten stellungnahme
ganz genauso und im grunde fragt man bei
der grippeschutzimpfung ja auch nicht
nach dem hersteller sondern man möchte
eine gute impfungen bekommen und die
bekommt man mit egal welcher dieser zwei
hersteller und auch als arzt möchte ich
das betonen dass wir mit beiden
impfstoffen sehr gute erfahrungen haben
und wir natürlich durch die bank sehr
sehr gute auch immunantworten gegen
beide impfstoffe sehen am ende bleibt
also noch mal festzuhalten
wir haben die besten stoffe in
ausreichender menge wir haben ein hoch
ansteckendes virus das sich bei
niedriger impfquote wie wir jetzt leider
sehen relativ ungehindert verbreiten
können und unser gesundheitssystem an
die grenzen des leistbaren treiben wird
nur die impfung kann uns da rausholen
und deshalb müssen sich alle impfen
lassen vielen dank
danke herr plesser samt haben wir viele
fragen fangen sie gegen aus dem saarland
hessen an der winkel
[Musik]
dann müssen sich dann alle sechs monate
und sagen im abonnement
er sagte es gebe in seinen keine daten
so kann keine echten schutz
also das kann natürlich mit
abschließender sicherheit noch noch
niemand sagen einfach weil die booster
impfung gerade angelaufen sind
es ist so dass es zum dass wir das aus
erfahrung mit anderen impfstoffen wirken
dass gerade so ein zeitversetzte dritte
dosis daneben das immun gedächtnis
nochmal stärkt und sie dann eine
immunantwort bekommen die einfach lang
andauernder ist wir sehen das auch in
unseren eigenen untersuchungen ich habe
hier auch sogar die daten mitgebracht
selbst bei älteren menschen steigt es
kann ihnen auch gerne mal zeigen steigt
im prinzip nach sechs monaten sind die
hier unten nur nach der dritten sind vom
steigen die so hoch wie sie vorher noch
nie waren und selbst wenn die antikörper
mit derselben geschwindigkeit wieder
abfallen würden wie nach der zweiten
impfung hätten wir damit deutlich mehr
zeit aus meiner perspektive als wir das
nach der zweiten führung habe nicht im
grunde davon aus dass findet lang
anhalterin lang anhaltenden schutz
bekommen werden ich hab studien gesehen
zu den chinesischen impfstoffen die nach
der zweite in form sehr sehr rasch ihre
wirkung verlieren und nach der dritte
impfung zumindest über 100 tage also geh
mal daumen drei monate komplett stabil
geblieben sind daraus kann man das jetzt
nicht zwangsweise schließen dass wir mit
der 3 mit dem 3 dosis schema komplett
durch sind wir wissen ja auch nicht was
für tricks letzten endes des virus noch
drauf hat ob wir da irgendwann nochmal
nachschärfen müssen aber ich würde
denken dass wir jetzt erstmal mit der
dritten impfung die immunisierung
abgeschlossen haben das wäre meine
hoffnung aber im prinzip kann es
natürlich sein dass wir gelegentlich da
noch mal nachbessern müssen rinke
sie hat geschrieben dass stocker
bestätigte den wunsch nach autos sind
mit dem hotel das
berichtet das
blatt liegen sagen habe oder stand im
unternehmen ausgesprochen wandern jetzt
der kinder
also zuerst einmal sind wir wurden in
beständigen austausch natürlich mit
allen impfstoffherstellern insbesondere
auch mit biontech
und ja natürlich bemühen wir uns die
menge der verfügbaren dosen auch ab
nächster woche ich sage noch einmal weil
ich heute auch von ärzten die ich aus
der heimat kennen die sorge da war
kriegen wir heute unsere lieferung diese
woche wird alles ausgeliefert wie
bestellt 6 millionen dosen biontech
gehen heute zur minute sozusagen in die
versorgung in deutschland aber natürlich
wollen wir auch in den folgewochen wenn
es eben geht
das angebot weiter erhöhen dass man
zwischen zwei guten impfstoffen wählen
kann dessen bin ich auch persönlich aber
ja auch unser ministerium im gespräch
mit dem unternehmen
ich halte aber nichts davon über zahlen
zu spekulieren das bringt jetzt noch
mehr durcheinander wenn die dinge klar
sind wann was dann werden wir es auch
kommunizieren eine botschaft bleibt aber
weiterhin wichtig auch der impfstoff von
moderner
kann soll und muss mit in die versuchung
die herausforderung besteht jetzt gerade
darin und das ist eben auch das weil
einige der fragen konntet ihr das nicht
alles vielleicht schon vor zwei wochen
so sehen wir haben eigentlich seit ich
weiß nicht wir waren ja auch schon öfter
in pressekonferenzen seit sondern auch
für auffrischimpfung geworben hatten
aber eine relativ verhaltene nachfrage
über einen langen zeitraum
und dann so für ein zwei wochen hoch ab
und wir haben letzte woche noch eine
reihe von nachbestellungen und zusatz
lieferungen möglich gemacht weil wir
natürlich wollen dass schnellstmöglich
alles raus geht wir haben sollen noch
einmal möglich gemacht dass die
arztpraxen nachbestellen können er ist
letzte woche entgegen dem üblichen
rhythmus was auch richtig war aber das
alles führt dazu dass eben diese woche
unerwartet viel auf einmal abfließt das
wollte ich auch möglich machen
und das führt aber eben dazu dass wir
zumindest in den folgewochen ich sage
noch einmal zwei bis drei millionen
dosen ist ja nicht nichts jede woche an
biontech und darüber hinaus alles was
ein moderner bestellt wird werden
ausliefern können und wenn es gelingt
mit dem unternehmen bestimmte
lieferungen sozusagen vorzuziehen
zusätzlich möglich zu machen werden wir
das natürlich auch tun aber ich möchte
das halt erst konkret machen wenn es
konkret ist falls sonst glaube ich
bringt es eher noch mehr durcheinander
was die freiheit des kinder impfstoffs
an geht es auch das wichtig die ganze
europäische union bekommt die lieferung
am
20.12 plusminus die zulassung wird
wahrscheinlich herzlich ende dieser
woche erfolgen
und damit sind wir zurück hierbei bild
live mit dem bundesgesundheitsminister
der also eines macht erstmal nach diesem
feiertag desaster dem nächsten im
versagen der tatsache dass der bau und
dämmstoff unser lieblings impfstoff also
erstmal rationiert wurde sagt er nimmt
moderner und der hc professoren an seine
seite geholt die also sagen ist doch gar
kein problem das ist im zweifel sogar
der roadshow ist neben dem mercedes bei
und ex so sagte er
bundesgesundheitsminister eben also
erwirbt hierfür moderner und inmitten in
dieser debatte fragen wir uns aber warum
bestehen wir nicht noch mehr gibt es
noch irgendwelche möglichkeiten an mehr
bei und heranzukommen dazu jetzt diese
breaking news
[Musik]
erscheint nämlich tatsächlich rettung in
sicht im booster desaster und zwar kommt
die von den feldern direkt den feldern
von bei und tag die greifen jetzt den
minister unter die arme alles dazu hat
jetzt unser chefreporter peter tiede
hier bei uns im studio also irgendwann
danach die pressekonferenz und schon
kann es zu vermelden es gibt hilfe ja
immer wenn ich entspannt in der tinte
sitzt dann muss er gerettet werden kommt
selten da alleine raus diesmal wieder
aus mainz wieder von bayern takt und
zwar haben wir jetzt gerade erfahren
dass bei und heute um 13 uhr zahlen über
sondern über mögliche sonder lieferungen
von millionen dosen impfdosen an die
europäische kommission liefern würde die
kauft ja eigentlich central ein die hat
zentral eingekauft die meisten
europäischen staaten oder für alle
europäischen staaten deutschen ein paar
sonderbestellungen gemacht und auf
drängen deutschlands ist bei uns jetzt
nochmal in die lager gegangen hat nach
geguckt was ist möglich wo kann und
disponiert wer mit welchem kunden können
wir verschiebungen machen und jetzt soll
eine extra- lieferung von noch
unbekannter höhe von bayern tag an die
europäische kommission kommen und in
brüssel wird dann entschieden wie viel
von diesen extrawürste die man quasi
macht kriegt die jetzt je entspannter
notrettung man geht in berlin momentan
noch davon aus dass es zwischen acht und
zehn millionen dosen seien könnten die
bis jahresende extra gesondert über die
verträge hin ausgeliefert werden könnten
also dann könnte bayern tech tatsächlich
für fast alle die auch bayern tag haben
wollen ausreichend das wäre dann quasi
die rettung aus diesem schlamassel aus
diesem wirklichen desaster dass ihr
entspannen mit dieser rationierung
angerichtet hat mit diesem wirklich
großen verunsicherung damit käme man
darf wieder einigermaßen heil raus